Most of the time we don't have
this transition function,
and we don't have
the reward function either.
So the robot, or
the trader, whatever environment we're
in, has to interact with the world,
observe what happens, and work with
that data to try to build a policy.
So let me give you an example here.
Let's say we were in state S1.
So, that's what we observed there.
Our robot took action, A1.
I'm making this little subscript
to indicate which step in
this series of steps it's at.
We then find our self in S'.
And we get reward R.
Now this is an experience tubal.
This is very similar to experience
tubal in regression learning
where we have an X and
a Y paired together.
That's an experience tubal of you know,
when you observe this X you see this Y.
Here we're saying when you observe
the state, S1, you take action, A1,
you end up in this new state, at least
it's an example of you ending up in this
new state S1', and reward, R1.
Now we find ourselves in a new state S2,
but that's really,
this state is where we found our self.
We take some new action,
A2, we end up in some
new state, S2', and
we get a new reward, R2.
When we do this over and
over and over and over and
over again, gathering experience
tuples all along the way.
Now, if we have this trail
of experience tuples,
there's two things we can do with
them in order to find that policy pi.
The first set of approaches is called
model based reinforcement learning.
What we do is we look at
this data over time and
we build a model of T just by looking
statistically at these transitions.
In other words we can look a every
time we were in a particular state and
took a particular action.
And see which new states we ended up in.
And just build a tabular
representation of that.
It's not hard.
Similarly, we can build a model of R.
We just look statistically when
we're in a particular state, and
we take an action, what's the reward?
We can just average that
over all these instances.
Once we have these models,
we can then use value iteration or
policy iteration to solve the problem.
There's another set of
approaches called model-free.
And that's the type
we're going to focus on.
In particular we're going to
learn about Q-learning.
And model-free methods develop a policy
just directly by looking at the data.
And of course we'll
talk about those soon.